what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday november 9th uncle joey's
joint is brought to you by
hydrant listen the days are getting
shorter
it's getting colder outside and we can
feel
our energy getting sapped don't get sick
this winter hydrating
is the best thing you could do for your
health that's why i start my day with
hydrant
it helps me hydrate faster after a
workout
a bike ride around the neighborhood
this helps uncle joey feel tip top magoo
an adult it tastes tremendous hydrant is
a refreshing drink mixed powder
made with four key electrolytes your
body needs
sodium potassium magnesium and zinc
so do yourself a favor i got a deal for
you right now
25 off your first order go drink
hydrant.com
joey enter joey at checkout that's
drink hydrant.com joey
at the promo code joey for 25
off your first order health is wealth
don't risk it get 25
off at drink hydrant.com
joey thank you for sponsoring the show
the show is also brought to you by cbd
lion when it comes to cbd nobody does it
better
whether it's the gummy bears the bath
ball the infused tape
they got everything roll on cream
listen i live and die with cbd lion
go to cbd lion right now and pressing
joey and get 20 off your first order
delivered
right to your goddamn house go to
cbdlion.com right now
and read about cbd cbn
read learn before you go somewhere make
a bad decision
cbdlion.com press in
joey the church is also brought to you
by
do fasting intermittent fasting is one
of the most effective ways to lose
weight
but the trick is knowing when and how
long you should fast
so that it actually works and you're not
just starving for no reason
as you guys know after i turned 35
without the blow and everything
losing weight was my number one priority
do fasting the easiest three in one
solution
for weight loss especially if you're
struggling and now that you're in the
house
you're going to gain weight this is the
way
to lose weight you probably heard people
trying this and the benefits go just
beyond weight loss
you can reduce inflammation and bad
cholesterol also
get a fully personalized plan based on
your lifestyle
they'll tailor each plan to you
go to do fasting dot com slash joey
right now again
do fasting.com joey press code joey get
a six-month
fasting program with 50 off plus one
extra month that's seven months guys
if you start today you don't have to
worry about j i'm gonna wait till
january first
january first ain't gonna come and ain't
going to come
so start today and get this over with so
by the time january 1st comes
you're already in a rhythm and the
weight is falling off and you're getting
healthier
join now and speed up your weight loss
journey that's do fasting.com
joey for 50 off the six-month plan
and you get your seventh month free when
you use joey
who's better than you guys nobody i'm
here to take care of you
let's start this [__] jam candles
are [__] lit [__]
hey
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
greetings from podcastville you bad
[__]
welcome to uncle joey's joint monday
november 9th was a great week last week
but hey
this week is going to be a lot [__]
better
for starters let's uh give new jersey
thanks
for legalizing [__] medical marijuana
whatever recreational marijuana
uh for you people who think i had
something to do with it or whatever i
had nothing to do i don't know nobody i
don't know nothing
i just called around before i left and
they said it was gonna pull up be put on
the ballot i think it got shot down last
year the year before
and so i was hoping i can't vote all i
could do is send [__]
you know osmosis signals and that's
exactly what i did
and now we got it so for you
[__] who were hating on me
going
we're going to call the cops on joey
[Laughter]
call a cop people been calling the cop
for 30 years they suck my dick then they
just
suck my dick now so sorry that's all i
do anyway
i just smoked my reefer the other night
i went out and i did drink some
cocktails
two [__] cocktails i had two not one but
two
mimosas not mimosas the other [__]
cocktail sangria
but i tell you what i slept like a
[__] baby i realized because i went
there the week before and i had a mimosa
uh [__] sangria it's just a little
[__] glass too
six cat six weight watcher points but i
realized
when i came home that night i slept
[__] solid
i [__] slept like a tank did i get
drunk not at all
i slept like a [__] tank though so
this friday i had the opportunity
a buddy of mine goes you want to have a
[__] drink i'll meet you over there
and we'll have a [__] sangria and
that's exactly what i did i went over
had my two sangria
12 weight watcher points thank god i
rode my bike that day
and [__] tip top magoo i slept like a
baby
so i think that you're going to convert
your uncle joey into a red wine drinker
not like with the [__] glass like a
half a [__] i don't like glass wines
whenever i see somebody drinking gla
wine out of a glass i want to like at
home like you know
to think that they're on dynasty or on
some [__] high level show
it makes my blood pressure go up one
over a [__] hundred so
i mean i drink it on anything a [__]
a [__] juicer yeah i don't give a
[__] a coconut
i don't give a [__] a zombie glass you
know
i just hate those people you know i
spilt wine
while i was doing a zoom on my [__]
ipad what are you [__] why is wine
close to your [__] ipad anyway but
who gives a [__]
speaking of zooms all right listen
when mike and i put together uncle
joey's joint
we told you that we're gonna get better
every week
we're gonna do different things yes it's
tape with an iphone
yes the bar had covered yes we had
problems we stumbled upon
but we kept pushing along like listen
and this is what life is about
it's pushing along you know if you want
to be a [__] victim you could be a
[__] victim
but in my world there's no [__]
victims you push along
and you start somewhere and every week
you add on and every week you try to be
better and better and better
what you do and people going to try to
kick in the [__] stomach
just like they did with stand up just
like they did when i tried to act
just like i did when i tried to do the
original church and the beauty and the
beast
me i don't listen to you [__] i
agree with you
i don't give a [__] i just know from
life that i'm gonna be
way better and better so this week mike
and i
decided to add the blue sweatshirt
to maybe add a little contour to the
[__] podcast
because some people think by adding a
different shirt or you know i've had
different [__] uh advices from people
said no not really mike you know i'm
just saying that you know everybody's a
[__]
podcast [__] expert so people always
go maybe it's
you should need a new table maybe listen
what you need is [__] verbage
what you need is communication and what
you need is your heart and soul to come
through
any other thing that you might have
explosives or
cameras on [__] what are those things
that they
are [__] drone yeah i have a camera
and a drone
it'll give you a different look i don't
need a different look i'm ugly from
every angle
i know that you know what i'm saying and
forget from the bat my ass is flat i got
a bald spot like a [__] jew
you know i got problems like everybody
else but this week
against my best you know interest
because i have to it's like me moving
i got to do what's best for everybody i
decided
to add the zoom feature to our little
[__] uncle joey's join on a monday
to give you a different perspective to
give you uh
just to let you know where we're going
with this [__] podcast
every week we're gonna add on and we're
gonna have different ideas it's just
like the [__] patreon you know this
the smoke thing didn't work
the crowd sourcing didn't work for us so
now we got to figure something else out
so maybe we'll give you an extra album
of the week we're supposed to do two
let's do four i got a thousand arms i
can review so i don't give a [__] you
know me i'll do albums till the end the
[__] time
but i'm doing them in order which is
really weird
because i want you to know the order of
which my
music came up on like how i saw it and
how it
was presented to me so it's kind of
different it's not like uh
whatever list so it's even like that
like
we're adding different things as we go
along because we don't know
what we can do what we can't do once
this covert is over
we're definitely gonna have some [__]
guests in this [__] and we're
definitely gonna light a [__] thing
on fire
and i'm definitely gonna get an office
where i could yell and scream and go off
with my daughter not upstairs and i have
to disrespect her
but for today we gave you a different
perspective
we gave you a zoom with a dear friend of
mine who i love for years
i love she's [__] beautiful but i've
always been in love with the balls
because if you're going to be a female
comic you better show up with a [__]
strap
if you're gonna be on they're not
putting enough women on the lineup well
you gotta earn your [__] way up on
the lineup i'm sorry to tell you that
and uh it's not by [__] doing sexual
favors nothing this by being [__]
funny
so uh today i bring you a little
interview we do it with zu
sue costello my girl out of boston
[__] tremendous comic tv show she was
in the fighter i mean she's the real
deal
she was up there running with lenny
clark all the [__] boys
30 years i hope you enjoy it here it is
what's happening you bad [__]
we got my girl today my
[__] friend old school one of the
best comics
[__] savagery ran with the boys
never made a [__] peep miss sue
costello out of boston mass
what's happening you sexy savage what's
up
how are you sue i'm so good i i have
literally
never been better you look great in the
fighter
thank you very much when i saw you on
there i was happy for you
you're still in the [__] game you're
still beautiful what's happening
thank you everything's going good my
whole career it's finally coming to
fruition
how long have you been banging out for a
[__] sue how long have we been
banging it out for sure
30 30 years for me 29 for me sue
so if anybody has their right to raise
their hand
both of us do so always know that
yeah we do what's going on in your world
oh so much so uh so you know i had
costello back in 1998
right so what's going on in my world is
the the
the way i've seen the world so costello
was a lot about the disenfranchised
middle class
it was about the healthcare system the
education system
uh sexism and uh but i was young
and i was just out of dorchester i was
just out of boston so i went to
hollywood with no nepotism
so i was like uh chum for the shocks
and so but but the show it's a it's a
duality that goes on with my career
because they did let me on tv because
i'm i'm very appealing to the working
class
but then they try to manage me and
control me because of the sexism
and because they don't want the middle
class to rise which is where why we're
where we're at right now politically how
long did your show last
for it was on for eight episodes no we
filmed eight there were four episodes
but even the first they so what happened
with costello was they thought it was
going to be the best thing
that ever happened like the guys who
produced uh home improvement
and roseanne did my show and the night
of the pilot
the marines were literally hanging off
the rafters screaming
the guys it was always the guys too
which was so interesting
i mean the girls like me but the guys
really and they were like we [__]
love you
sue and so they also dollar signs and
these guys who produced home improvement
and uh and roseanne first of all they
chased me around the whole time telling
me don't be like roseanne don't be like
roseanne don't be like roseanne
and all i keep thinking is i should have
been like [__] roseanne
roseanne was on for how many years and
what mine was on for like four episodes
and so uh they were they were already
established at this point so they so i
had this other woman
co-create the show with me and they left
they abandoned her
and she ended up having to run the show
but she didn't know how to run the show
so they thought it was just going to
sail like um
like home improvement did once they saw
the pilot they thought it was at slam
dunk
and they put me on but what they did so
it's so what's going on in my career now
is all reflected back then so what they
did was
they moved king of the hill which was a
male driven show and it was
it was that it was on fox and it was the
uh the main
that was fox's biggest show it was their
their foundation
they moved king of the hill to tuesday
night to launch my show
but it was a male-driven show no guys
were going to watch a woman's show
without
a reason so what they did was they
tanked king of the hill
by doing that and the night in my
premiere mark maguire hit a 60-second
home run so it got preempted
so all the press building up to it [__]
the bed
and the press looking back now colin
quinn me and colin had a big talk about
this
the press were so provoked by my
middle-classness that i have an accident
they were very
provoked by it which is what's happening
right now in the media the elite media
they've gotten way worse they don't want
to hear it which is going on with the
divide in our country they're
they're [__] on the people that are
voting for trump and i'm like this is
this is why there's
this is why they're voting for trump
because you [__] on us
and so uh back when i saw it so
everything that's happening now
was going on with costello while the
sexism was very strong
so it's a duality that goes on with my
careers like i really i pushed through
in a way that's never been done
and then the biggest thing that could
happen like even mahmoud
he's he was done they said he did
steroids so i'm like oh great a drug
addict guy ruined my career
so what happened with cbs after that so
then so what i
so cbs les moonves gave me my first two
deals
he gave me my first deal where i did a
pilot called paulie dodge
the second deal i was supposed to be on
murphy brown for 13 episodes looking
back now because i just went back in
with cbs i realized
he pushed me on murphy brown because i
was supposed to go on another network
so all the talk about him [__] with
women's careers
is true he promised me 13 episodes on
murphy brown i went on murphy brown
because i thought that was the humble
move to make instead of going on townies
which would have which was a new show
and i thought that was too egotistical i
was like if i go on murphy brown
i'll get the exposure i'll learn from
the best and then i'll do my own show
instead of being an egomaniac thinking i
want my own show
well she kicked me off before i even
went in front of the camera and i was
devastated at the time
now looking back i see it's because he
he didn't want me to go on abc so he
forced me on murphy brown and she flexed
her muscles and kicked me off
so everything that's come on the press
about less about him [__] with
women's careers
is true with the career with the
business aspect of it
and then uh there was a pilot called
queens
he called me at midnight one night and
he said sue i just fired illiana douglas
get on a plane tomorrow and come take
over for
so i take over for ileana douglas i
shoot the pilot they don't pick it up
everybody sees me on on queens and says
sue costello deserves their own show
that's how i got costello so every move
in my career was based on
my acting and my ability it was never
just a fluke and everybody's always like
oh sue just got all these deals i'm like
no actually i did a pilot and then for
my acting i got the
second deal and then from the second
deal i got costello
so then after costello i was i was like
i can't take this is the sexism is too
much and i always wanted to do it like
the boys
i've always been around the boys i was
on tough crowd you know
i've always been around everybody and
they've always invited me in and they've
managed me
i've been managed by the men and i and i
and
it's just a fact they keep you close but
they keep you down
it's in because there's more men than
women it's just and i always say this
like
when they go on tour like when when dan
cook and those guys and bobby kelly went
on tour
in a tr uh trailer i'm like do you think
that
they're all going to sit around and go
you know what let's invite sue too
it's not going to happen they're not
going to invite a woman where they're
all being boys they're doing all their
dick stuff or whatever they do
it just wasn't going to happen it's like
it's not gonna happen so all along i was
like how do i do what the boys do
how do i break through so i wrote my
play i started writing my play
which is about my life which is about i
took myself out of hollywood
and wrote my play and i did performed it
for 20 years
in new york in new york in la everywhere
i did performed it everywhere i
performed it over and over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
again
because i wanted to get so strong that i
could perform there's no props or
anything with the play and the play is
about my whole life and my career
it's about hollywood about getting
exploited it's about how the system is
set up to hurt us
it's it's about everything i tried to do
with costello because when costello got
cancelled i was like i'm not
i still have my voice there was
something about the fame thing i didn't
want to be famous
i wanted to be creative and i didn't
like all the
on the unfairness i didn't like the
sexism i didn't like the way the
agents exploited you i didn't like that
they made you sign a deal where you they
put a lien on your career
i said i'm not [__] doing this and i
went to therapy i told my therapist i
want to learn how to do this where i
don't have to pay any percentages
she's like oh sue if you can get over
your weaknesses there's nothing you
can't do
and so i worked really really really
hard on the play and the play got great
reviews
i got a standing ovation at the new york
uh comedy festival
and and nothing would happen with it so
it was like you want to talk about
building strength
i had everything that you could need but
nothing was happening with it so but i
never quit
and then one day i had a tour booked in
china so this is the sexism stuff that i
want to talk about practically
so the sex stuff that goes up that's
been gone with it going on with the guys
that's always gone on that's that's how
it was has always been
so now that it's cut that it started
coming out with the me too movement
the whole i was i was front and center
with the metoo movement because
the the end of the i've always wanted to
do it like the guys
the reason why i made a big uh move is
because i was supposed to go on tour in
china they came to me
and they said sue we want you to
headline in china i was booked at the
end of august
for six weeks or something and the guy
long story short
he was bullying me before i went to
china the booker
and so i had to stand up to him to make
sure that i didn't go to china by myself
and have somebody bully me
for six weeks so i stood up to him and
he pulled the china toro from underneath
me
so that ego thing with men has been as
it has been a real thing that's gone on
financially for women that is a fact
and so uh i i felt like completely
leveled again i was like oh my god this
is like the
millionth time that this has happened
i'm like i can't you know we can't book
more
time at the end of the summer because
people book in advance
so he crippled me financially and i was
sitting at my desk and i said what
should i do i said
i said i want to do it like the boys and
i said go see les moonves the voice came
down
and i emailed les moonves i hadn't seen
him in 20 years
and i said will you meet with me i need
advice because abc was coming to me
about doing a talk show they wanted me
to be on the view they wanted me to take
over for katie couric
and everybody the ifc was coming to me
because they were like so you're on
stage talking about what it's like to be
a woman and you're not angry you're
making it hilarious
so that was very enticing to them
because after he got fired or
no before in july 2017
okay and i told him an inkling of my
idea
my tv show idea an inkling and i talked
about my play
and he was like oh my god if this
thing's as good as you say it is and he
was like a mad dog he was like a [__]
animal i'm not joking it was business
it was business and uh and he kept
asking me how you making a living how
you making living how are you making a
living how you making a living how are
you making a living
and i was sitting on the couch and i
knew what he was doing i know what he
was doing he was trying
to find my weakness because that's what
they all done to me my whole career
financially is where they all
[__] me and so i told him on purpose
i said i've been broke and the reason
why i told him i was broke this is where
i started to learn how the boys do it
because i was like i'm going to put the
steak in front of the lion and i'm going
to see how the lion acts so i can
protect myself most people would tell
you don't tell them that you bro cause
they'll take advantage of you i'm like
no tell them
and see how he acts and sure enough he
uh
he went like a wild animal but at the
same time i didn't know what was
going on behind the scenes that they
were trying to get him out but they were
trying to get him out because of the
merger they weren't trying to get him
out because of the sex
but i had no idea while i was up in
front front and center with this so i
lived
front and center during the me too
movement and so i was a witness to all
of it
so like i was telling you on the phone
earlier i'm able to see how they just
totally [__] threw a couple guys
under the bus so that they could do
dirty business so i'm like never did i
think i would come forth as a voice
for men too but that's what's happening
so forget about me too it's men too
well so you're smart enough to know how
the comedy scene works i mean
listen if if they start [__]
uh canceling people they're gonna have
to cancel sinatra eventually
they're gonna have to cancel dean martin
you know the rat pack they're gonna have
you know
for years there was a way that things
were running you know
metal music music in particular you know
and women have stories and men have
stories i mean
if they really wanted to press charges
today they could throw jimmy page in
jail
for having a 14 year old girlfriend and
you know
this has been going on forever i'm happy
that it got brought up into the
limelight now i have a daughter
you know i have two daughters i have a
seven-year-old
and uh i don't
like what happened how it went down in
comedy
because everybody knew what they were
getting themselves into i think i think
that
when harvey weinstein took you to lunch
sue
and he got up and said let's go up to my
room to look at the script
you had an inkling of about what was
going to happen
as a woman are you not like i like to
hear it
what's that i like to hear what the guy
we got to let the guys talk
so that we can hear what what you're the
reason why it's gone on
is because guys have been told not to
have feelings and not to talk so they
act out so then if we're going to shame
guys more
guys need to be able to talk even if
what you're saying isn't comfortable and
even if it's wrong
we still need to be able to let you have
then you're not going to hurt me as much
if you're talking so okay so you tell me
that
and then i say and then i explain to you
i hear what you're saying
and then i say to you because there's a
little bit of truth in everything right
and i also think the dynamic was set up
where women were set up to have to use
their sexuality there's a whole
stuff that needs to be brought up but
the reason why it wasn't brought up is
because they use the metoo movement
to [__] throw everybody on the to the
bus they paid the metoo movement off
they didn't [__] and that's why the guys
are so mad
because they know it wasn't real if a
guy
got got same thing with george floyd
guys know that raping women is wrong no
guy is going to stand up and say we
should rape women
nobody's going to say that what happened
with george floyd is is
is right but it's because the media is
using it to cover and they're not doing
what's right that's causing the
provocation
it's why the men are frustrated because
they know it's [__] they know
they're being rewroted and they are
railroaded
they cbs used the metoo movement to
cover what they were doing with the
merger
they used the sex stories so that the
media would look at the sex story so
they wouldn't see what was going on with
their merger
and that's what the men are starting to
see so when you say that about harvey
weinstein
there's another layer to it women
brought those women to see harvey
weinstein
the problem that's going on right now at
least for myself i'm speaking for myself
is that i had to overcome my own women
weaknesses
because there's like there's a there was
a sick way of everybody operating to get
the power back so
women brought women to harvey weinstein
and that's a mechanism that goes on a
lot where the women help the men
to hurt the women so there was a trust
with the women because the women were
bringing them to him i'm not saying that
sex doesn't go on and it doesn't get
exchanged and everything but there's
that mechanism that goes on
that everybody doesn't see that the men
don't see so there's a trust
and they did it so they set up so that
you brought up the hobby thing
that's what they did in business with
the women so now all the whole year
while i was doing my business
the men would bring a woman in the
office with them that was the new me too
rule
and then i would sit in the office and i
would go oh the so they would make a
woman who's really brilliant
equal to the man bring her into the
office to be a watchdog so now they're
knocking the woman down
and she has to watch just sit there and
pretend like she's watching that he's
not going to sexually harass her
but the woman the woman that's equal to
the man who works with the man
is forced to feign empathy to me
so that the guy can still [__] me
financially so you see it's
that's why everybody's frustrated
because they know it's [__] they
know the bullshit's going on but they
don't know how to get
underneath to the bottom of it so these
so what's they just keep building false
narratives to cover what's really going
on underneath which is the business
so i gotta ask you a question let's
narrow it down away from hollywood
okay let's talk about in the comedy club
world okay
what did you experience in the comedy
club world
and what did let's go with that one
first and then we'll go to the second
part of this
what was your experience with comedy
clubs i mean you're a [__] savage
i've seen you around men and
i respect you around men because you
turn into one of us
i've said crazy [__] around you and
you've never [__] flinched
because you knew you were smart enough
to know that this is a boy's room
this is a [__] boy's room what do you
[__] think you're gonna hear in a
boy's room
prayer that we love our wives no
we talk about disgusting things i go
watch football on sunday at my friend's
house
women run out of there women run out of
there because it's men
in their primal [__] state every
nationality gets a [__] whatever
you know [__] plots what
camel toes you hear [__] that you're not
supposed to hear i don't want my
daughter here
how did you put up with it all those
years
well i've always i put up with it
because there was also
uh there was a more sophisticated thing
that i had to do
so say take tough crowd for an example
we were on tough crowd one of my
favorite episodes on tough crowd was
so i described this recently about
because first of all i put up with it
because i didn't know any different and
i knew i wanted to keep going i left
boston because of the sexism
i've always stood up for myself and i've
suffered in my career because i've stood
up for myself they [__] leveled me
uh what's his facebook bill bloom and
rice tried to [__] me how to do it he
wanted me to do my special in boston
i'm from boston i just sold out the
women's comedy festival and laughed
boston
and i wanted to do my special there and
he said okay it's gonna be nine this is
what listen to how they do it
it's gonna be nine thousand dollars a
night uh a show you have to do two shows
and you can't sell any tickets because
you won't sell any
he was completely trying to [__] me
behind the scenes so the way i put up
with it
is i started i rented out the vfw haul
in boston and sold that out instead and
got it
got an equal thing in the boston globe
compared to the to the wilbur
that's how i did it he i have an email
where he said you're a [__] loser
so all this stuff was going on this is
how i did it i just kept moving forward
but the tough crowd thing so this is
what people i what i did was i just kept
managing my emotions and i kept
understanding so you're talking about
the men
when you're primal right i just i tried
to get more
like rational and i'm like okay guys
when they go out with their guy friends
say they can't be vulnerable because
they'll get the balls busted
they can't and then i'm like oh oh so
that's what's happening
so i get rational about that and then i
look at tough crowd and i go
okay so tough crowd colin quinn and all
the boys had a regular job a regular
paying job they were regular so they
were very solid in their jobs
they they were making money they they
had camaraderie because they saw each
other all the time
and then they would bring one woman in
and circle her in every once in a while
so we had to come in with these guys who
had the camaraderie
the financial uh stability and
have it be one girl with with what four
guys
and kill people don't understand the
level of what it
that's the dynamic that that needs to be
vocalized forget all the throwing the
guys under the bus and everything
guys i don't think you'd interview
anybody and say i'd like to rape women
and if they wouldn't even say it out
loud anyways but what's going on is
we're not having a conversation
about the actual fact and i had to get
over my own like
resentment and and victimhood i had to i
just had to have like radical
forgiveness
you have to you have to you have to you
start putting a victim label on you
you're never going to move forward like
right now they're organizing
to sue the comedy store why you know
i don't know i just heard through the
grapevine that a bunch of women
don't feel like they were getting equal
treated and stuff like that you know
i used to count the lineups every night
when i i
went back to the store in 2014
and then a couple of women mentioned
things to me
like in 2015 and 16 and if you noticed
i always put women on my podcast i
always had women on my podcast since day
one i
i didn't want to create that barrier and
i treated them just like the men
and i talked like if i had a man in the
room
i i always gave him the respect they
deserved
uh but people still weren't happy with
that
you know i i don't know you know i don't
know how to please everybody you can't
please everybody
no but i know this guy
i was gonna say the sophistication with
tough crowd you asked me how i handled
it with it
so i realized i can't fight all the guys
because then i'm just gonna sound like a
loud [__] crazy lady and that's not
i don't want to be allowed i want to do
my comedy i just wanted to do my comedy
i was like i just want to be funny and
do my comedy and i've had al martin tell
me
al martin said right to my face sue
costello you kill more than any other
any other comic i've ever seen and i
hesitate to tell you that because you'll
have the power
my friends told me they would say sue
the guys are intimidated by you because
you [__] kill and it would
kill my spirit because i would be the
club owners would crush me because they
were
a lot of them were failed comics and
they didn't like that i killed the way i
did
and i was never trying to take the guys
down i was just trying to hard flex how
[__] hilarious i was charlie murphy
he used to god rest his soul that man
gave me my props like nobody's business
he used to say sue costello's [__]
gangster he probably i know you were a
gangster all right
when i saw you in the store in 98 you
intimidated me
i thought you were a gangster and it's
so funny
right but then i don't want to hurt the
men i had to break through that i was
like
i finally realized i was like oh they
think i want to hurt them
i don't want to hurt peop i love men i
just tweeted i said i love romantic
justice i hate sexism
like i'm finally able to vocalize my
femininity
and so i'll talk about tough crowd in a
second but also i started to learn
that the word woman is for man
and and if i stayed in my angry feminist
crazy like pain and with justified pain
then i wouldn't have saw what that meant
and what it means is we have an energy
that can call forth the best in men and
that's what i'm learning how to do
there's a bit of a like that i have to
do i'm from boston i got the balls i can
but guys like that like that's how guys
respond it's like wake them up and then
you call for what the best side of them
and that's what men want to do
even when you're dating somebody a man
wants to please you
he wants to feel useful he wants to plea
so if we break it down go back to basics
and get rid of this weird
it's almost a perversion that's happened
with the sex stuff it's perverted it's
like why are we
so perverted and so with tough crowd
what i learned how to do
so one episode they had they were
talking about how women were becoming
men
women are becoming men women are
becoming men so i know i've i've
learned over the years jay thomas artie
lange i know how to hold my space
and then go in and say what i need to
say and not react to what five men are
saying because i know that's never going
to win
and so we it's a so patrice so the
beginning of tough crowd
we used to have a fourth act right and
so i remember i was sitting there and
the fourth act said uh
sue costello's flat ass on the on the
monitor i go what the what is that
what is that and the producer was like
oh you're not supposed to see that oh
you're not supposed to see that i go
what is that
she goes that's patrice o'neill's fourth
act i go i'm gonna [__] get him
i'm gonna get him and my whole focus on
the tough crowd was to get patrice
and uh they were all talking about how
men uh how women are turning into men
now if i was
weak i would start yelling and then i'd
look weak to the audience
because the guys don't know people don't
know what's going on behind the scenes
they don't know that the guy's a
camaraderie that's for they're just
looking at us like women aren't funny
because we're screaming
so i started to learn that i started to
get very sophisticated and so i waited
and i waited i waited and i said what do
you mean
i said men are turning into women right
before our very eyes i go look at
patrice he's transforming into aretha
franco
franklin right now patrice fell
overlapping
and it was funny because the guys would
email me after tough crowd and they'd be
like sue your brilliance is intimidating
and then i'd get confused because i'm
like well how come the guy's on laughing
i'm like oh the guy's not laughing
because they don't want people to think
i'm like there was a whole dynamic that
was going on that people weren't seeing
and so it was manifesting as like
women screaming so nobody was getting a
handle on it so i started to get very
sophisticated with it
i had to yeah i haven't gotten huh
you had to sue because the only way you
would last 30 years
this is why you've lasted 30 years
because you've grown you've adjusted
along the way
and you you know i i've never
you know you just kept growing and you
never stopped
and i love people yeah you do i love
men good for you love men
and i also see that women are part of
the problem too and i'm not afraid i
grew up in boston
i'm not afraid of girl gangs i'm like
wait a minute what the hell's going on
here maybe everybody's afraid of the
angry women
i was afraid of them and i'm like wait a
minute i grew up with the honeybees in
charleston they [__]
threatened me all the time i was like
[__] you i'm like i'm not afraid
i started to get like i'm like i'm not
afraid and i also am righteous i know
what's right
i was upfront so i negotiated a tv deal
with cbs
while les moonves was going down that
has provisions for women
and protections for artists that has
never been done before
because they thought i was a [__]
idiot blonde girl from boston
so i had cbs sign my nda to protect my
uh ip after they robbed they tried to
rob it from me
and i still beat them and had them sign
my nda to protect my ip
then they tried to give me a deal and
[__] me and i [__] out negotiated
them
and they tried to steal my script before
less went down and i
caught them and then they retaliated
against me and i still caught them
and they they thought every because
everybody was coming at me for a sex
story because i was in the office with
les
and then they kept coming to me like the
new york times came to me oh
you were in the fraternal investigation
they were they were questioning less
about you and i'm like why
i'm like i have a deal what the [__] is
going on here and they were so shady
that they helped me figure out what the
[__] happened and now i see what
happened they use the metoo movement to
[__] push
less out of the cb out of cbs and they
gave me a deal that they didn't honor
because they didn't think anybody was
ever going to see it because they were
going to make me look like a [__] they
were going to take my
script the less article was going to
come out they were going to say sue was
in the office with less we don't know
what happened
and push me to the side and steal my tv
idea and i [__] beat him
that's how you do it as a woman that's
how you [__] flip the tables that's
how you stand up and you [__] flip
the tables that's how you do it
sue you have been a breath of fresh air
to talk to
after the last eight months with
everybody [__] jumping up and down
let me ask you one last question sue
okay when you were at the store those
two years
three years did you feel anything weird
only from joe rogan that's it well not
even sexual it was not sexual i've had
guys grab my ass i've had club owners
tell me to take my shirt off
and i'll get my check i've had a lot of
i mean i've had people like
lots of stuff like that go on tons and
tons of that stuff but
take your shirt off or you won't get
your check yeah
in the office in the back
i don't think there's any guy in america
that would say sue should be treated
like that i really don't
i don't think that then there's anybody
that thinks i should get treated like
that
and i think i could prove a million
times over how funny i am
i've been frustrated i can prove it for
you i'm not worried
about the funniness it's the attitude
what do you mean yeah yeah listen man
it's how you go into this is a woman
a a funny woman told me one a story one
time she goes when i move towards
two options i can either suck dick i'll
put my ponytail under my hat
and become one of the boys and she goes
i went with the second option
and that's where i am today but now what
i'm doing
i want to go further joey and maintain
my femininity i want to go even further
and be like oh being a feminine woman
is actually going to help us all it's
going to
help manage the men's aggression if i
stay feminine if i stay loving if i stay
adorable and funny which is what i we
always have been and i'm like how did i
even
all i ever wanted to do was be funny and
get paid for it that's it
i mean i got paid less in vegas joey
just recently they paid the middle guy
less
more than me it made me do more work and
i went on stage and i [__] called it
out
and then the boxer tried to like scare
me to throw me off stage i was like [__]
you i've been thrown out of strip clubs
in [__] canada by my neck go ahead
throw me out
i don't even care
i want my money and i don't wanna i'm
not mad at you you need your [__]
money
i do i just want my money and i want to
be funny
i shouldn't make that the name of my
[__] my special i want my money and i
want to be funny now so you have a
podcast
i have my suit tv show i do it every day
every day what time five o'clock on
facebook
and it's building and building because i
talk about politics i talk about this
me too stuff i talk about the working
class i talk about how we're going to
end up it's going to go beyond the race
it's going to go beyond the gender and
it's going to turn into the 99
the general strike we're all going to
get empowered because we're going to see
where they're trying to keep us separate
they're trying to make the girls and the
guys fight they're trying to make the
black and the white
fight so that the one percent can keep
us down and i'm like not today
[__]
not today satan
[Laughter]
so i want you to circle i want you to
circle back with me in like three weeks
all right we get this system down more
and you and i are going to get deeper
into this
because this was a trial today for us
and it worked
yesterday i feel like i'm so happy i
feel like me and you will be good
together because we really are we're a
blue collar we're we're salt of the
earth
you're beautiful you still look
beautiful thank you god bless you
i feel beautiful i just recently found
out that you dated
my brother for a while who's your
brother my irish brother
greg fitzsimmons i never knew that greg
was my boyfriend for four years
i lived i never knew that that's how i
got to new york
i never knew that i loved that man with
all my heart
if there's somebody i miss in la it's
that irish [__] sucker
he was going to cuba i had him going to
cuba my aunt was going to pick him up at
the airport
before coving that's how much i love
greg vince image
yeah he was my boyfriend he's the reason
why i moved to new york i
never knew that dude so just [__]
maybe a month ago
yeah that's how my how bad i am we used
to do
he comes to me what's up he used to
coach me with the stand up and try to
control me
and i would [__] up every time on the
stage by accident because he was trying
to control me so much and then
like when nancy carrigan was in the
olympics i remember he's like you got to
do this
you got to do that you got to do this
you go to that and i'm a free spirit and
i got on stage and
not tonya harding and when i got here i
was supposed to say that i look like
tanya hatting and i said i looked like
nancy carrigan and he's like what are
you doing i'm like
you put too much pressure on me
[Laughter]
i'm a free spirit i'm not like a
well sue i'm happy for you i'm happy
that we got in touch
i'm happy you were the first guest on
the joint
even though i couldn't get you on the
church that week i wanted to make it up
to you
i love it and i want you to know i love
you and i support you in any
venture and if i could be on suit tv yes
let me know i'm going to and i'll just
you doing this joey and giving me the
the uh visibility is helping me just
letting people sleep in
my natural habitat i'm not here to hold
you down
i'm here to give you light you're here
to give me light and i'm just
i just want to be funny that's it yeah
we're a team
and i want you to circle back with me
every few weeks
all right no i would love it sounds good
i love you have a great week you have
any dates coming up you want to plug
no i haven't i haven't been going on i
can't i'm i just moved
the method no we got nothing i thought
boston was going to open up a little bit
but it didn't but i'm going to move
forward with the cbs thing and now
and with my tv show so i still have my
script my script is all about bringing
america together
i didn't let them take it it's mine
still and i'm going to come through
they're going to have journalists
they're going to write the story about
what was going on so when i come through
everybody's going to go
can't argue with sue garcelle being a
bad [__]
[Laughter]
and you let them know here on uncle
joey's joint cox
i love you sue costello love you too
there you go
[__] i hope you enjoyed my little
tate
with sue costello sue costello is great
i support her fully
and i'm looking forward to doing her
show hopefully this week we'll have some
more zoom guests for you
uh just to break it up a little bit you
know me and then once
i got things happening i got things in
the works if you guys know anything
about one thing
about lee he told me once that
everything i do is very cunning it's
very
you know i i think it out and it's very
thoughtful
why do one thing when you could do one
thing and it branches out to three
things
do you follow what i'm saying to you
everything has to be accurate everything
has to be by the mark
why would i want to go out on the road
and hold myself out right now when i got
no material that wouldn't be justice to
you
or justice to me so i do everything by
the [__] book
and yes i'm hard on myself because
listen that's what the problem is
nobody's hard on themselves nobody calls
themselves a fat
[__] slob get your [__] together you
[__]
you know when i say those things in the
morning that's what i'm feeling in my
heart
you got to get up and you got to get the
[__] out there nobody's going to give
you [__] dick
those things i say are the same things i
say to myself i tame them down for you
[__] because i don't want to
hurt your feelings
but i say horrible things to myself so
i'm very tough on myself
because if i'm not tough on myself who's
going to be tough on me life
no life is tough enough you got to be
disciplined you got to be [__] tough
and you got to stick with it if it was
up to
you guys i'd be off the [__] air you
know if it was up to
with anything would stand up any
endeavor you want to do any double you
want to do
there's always one [__] that
puts it down right there's always one
guy that has to make a [__] comment
to try to deflate your [__] dream
[__] that don't try to deflate my dream
because you're not gonna [__] work
your dream is your dream so we added the
zoom on this week we hope you enjoy it
you know me dawg i'm here for you
[__] i'm not looking for
nothing
i'm just looking to cover that one week
of entertainment two weeks of
entertainment
i'm looking to let you know it's gonna
be all right and i'm looking to let you
know that i'm going through the same
things you're going through
we're doing it [__] together thank
you for watching uncle joey's joint
and i'll see you guys wednesday morning
tip
top magoo ready to [__] go if you
need to see more joey if you want to see
the album of the week
subscribe to patreon i think the album
of the week is a great idea
eventually somebody's going to knock my
head off last week we did the [__]
great briar album so
if you haven't see it knock yourself out
we're probably gonna add
i'll let you guys know on patreon but
we're probably gonna add a code
to the vimeo and just release it to the
church uh
the tier members all right guys i love
you [__] have a great week
and now for a word from my [__]
thank you again for listening to the
joint and again it's brought to you by
hydrant
listen hygiene is a refreshing drink
mixed powder made with four key
electrolytes
your body needs sodium potassium
magnesium and
zinc you're like joey what do i need
hydra because
you don't want to get sick this winter
hydrating is the best thing you could do
for your health that's why i start my
day with hydrate
it tastes tremendous and it helps you
hydrate faster
after a workout a bike ride with my
daughter whatever a little walk
i drink my little drink and tip top
magoo i'm ready to rock i feel a lot
better
why because you got an extra boost so
try hydrant immunity it's got all the
vitamins you want
a b 6 b 12 c
d plus ginger and don't forget turmeric
drink it hot
or cold hydrant is backed by 100
satisfaction guarantee if you don't love
it if you don't love it
if you don't love it send it back for a
full refund
try hiding today and save up to 25
on your first order again what the hell
are you waiting for
i got a special deal like every other
day
25 off your first order so go to
drinkhydrant.com
joey enter code joey at checkout very
important
that's drink hydrant.com slash joey
enter pro como
joey for 25 percent off your first order
remember you can't do dick without your
health health is wealth
don't risk it get 25 off at drink
hydrant.com
joey church is also brought to you by
cbd lion one of my favorites out there
why because they reduced inflammation
anxiety it helps you with all that you
who the [__] am i i got a ged you gotta
go to cbd lion
for the [__] read read read read
don't just go to a store and buy cbd you
gotta buy
the cbd that's tailored for you and by
you reading the information on cbd lion
you can see what's gonna work for you is
it the cream
is it the back wall is it the
kinesiology tape
who the [__] knows go to cbdlion.com
right now
and press in joey and get 20 off your
order all right that's all i got to tell
you
the joint is also brought to you by
do fasting listen losing weight is a
[__]
it really is and right now we're going
into a weight
panda pandomium here everywhere you turn
there's cookies
i live in jersey everybody got a pizza
in their house how are you going to live
with everybody got a pizza in your house
when you're 14 you can eat two slices
and nothing happens because you're
running around all day
getting chased by the cops but once
you're an old man like me you eat two
slices a day
you got a string on your ass then people
floating you around
you don't need that right now is the
time to get healthy
do fasting is the easiest three in one
solution for weight loss
you probably heard people trying this
and the benefits go
way beyond weight loss you can reduce
inflammation
bad cholesterol do fasting is the most
comprehensive fasting program
complete with meal plan and a workout
routine that'll help you reach
guaranteed results this isn't a diet
where you're hungry all the time
you can still eat normally just at
certain times of the day
go to their website take a quick quiz
and based on your answers
they'll generate a specialized program
that is perfect for you
now is the time to take care of yourself
guys
get it done with do fasting go to do
fasting.com showy and press encode joey
and get a six month
fasting program 50 or
plus one extra month totally free sound
familiar
i'm trying to push you people in the
right direction join now
speed up your weight loss journey that's
do fasting.com
joey for 50 off a six-month plan
and get your seven month free when you
use
code joey i want to thank new fasting
i want to thank cbd lion and i want to
thank hydrant
but most importantly i want to thank you
guys for having my back
stay black have a great week i got
nothing this week
but i'll be around i love you
[__] thank you for being on
patreon
thank you for watching uncle joey's
joint
there you go i want fire department
coming in and [__]
look who it
welcome to is joey's joy
[Music]
you